the problem presented by nurdles
trillions of small plastic pellets
produced by petrochemical giants
leftover pellets have been escaping into
waterways in oceans for decades but only
lately has serious action been taken to
figure out what can be done that
includes a monumental settlement in
Texas where we traveled to ground zero
for this issue picking up a shovel full
of pellets and this is copses Creek take
a trip up Cox Creek off the Gulf of
Mexico and it's impossible to miss this
gigantic petrochemical Factory
that's a massive plant what sometimes
harder to see is what's finding its way
out of it countless plastic pellets
sometimes called nurdles how many
pellets are going into the water on a
daily basis they manage to scoop up 79
billion in two years Diane Wilson is a
fourth-generation Fisher woman who used
to captain a shrimp boat this is the
polyethylene powder that's all over the
bay
she is now an environmental activist
fighting one of the largest plastics
manufacturers in the world this was
never the plan to go from a fisher woman
to an environmental no i'm people don't
believe it but i am normally very quiet
i'm a introvert so why this because it
fell flat in my lap the Taiwanese
conglomerate Formosa Plastics first
opened this factory in 1983
it now covers 2500 acres of land near
Port Lavaca Texas trillions of
polyethylene plastic pellets like these
are made here the first step in making
products that we use every day from
plastic bottles to bags
clothing and electronics but billions of
plastic pellets are also lost and find
their way into waterways and eventually
oceans many wash back up onto the beach
so this is thousands and thousands of
nurdles from the most recent high tide
line chase tunnel is the founder of the
nurdle Patrol which began tracking
pellets after a massive spill near
Corpus Christi last year it is the
weirdest name you've ever heard but it's
a big problem right I think that's what
draws a lot of people to it is they
think nurdle I've never heard of a
turtle you know what is that and then
you get into talking about well it's
plastic and it shouldn't be in the
environment we know for a fact that
there's a laundry list of over 200
species that are eating these pellets
and then there's also concern about what
these pellets once they're in the
environment they're absorbing PCBs PAHs
DDT's you know all those acronyms we
hear about harmful chemicals these
absorb those chemicals accumulating on
our beaches in our waterways as we speak
exactly the hot spot over here it's
estimated as much as 250,000 tons of
nurdles enter the ocean each year we can
tell based on the colors and the period
of time they've been out and the sign
this has been happening over many
decades in North America the problem is
worst in the Gulf this is really
painting as a picture of where the
highest concentrations are all the way
from Mexico's Yucatan Peninsula to the
Florida Keys Diane Wilson began
collecting pellets on the waterways she
used to fish meticulously documented
where and when they were found and now
her work 30 plastic tubs filled with
evidence has led to a record-breaking
settlements Formosa Plastics agreed to
pay 50 million dollars to help local
fishermen an environmental cleanup
projects in the area when you first
heard that Formosa was going to settle
what did you think I was just kind of I
was in kind of state of shock about it 1
million of that 50 million dollar
settlement will go to fund tunnels
nurdle Patrol this isn't just one
company that is the bad actor here is
probably industry-wide based on the data
that we've accumulated through neural
patrol do you think the company or
companies who are responsible for doing
this are committed to fixing it I don't
think that these companies want their
pellets out into the environment i I
think that it is cheaper to leave the
product on the ground after it spilled
than it is to clean it up
they don't wanna spend the money to
clean it up all right how do you make
them do that regulations both tunnel and
Diane Wilson say the formosus settlement
is not the end of their fight in fact
just the opposite
every accessible point in the Gulf of
Mexico has been sampled Tunnel gets new
reports of pellets washing ashore every
day there are currently 46 companies in
Texas alone in manufacturing plastics
and tunnels map showing the size of the
problem is only growing do you feel like
people are getting the message about
this well when I give presentations one
of the key points that I make is you
know why are we doing all this
so I have a picture of my kids holding
up a bottle of plastic pellets and I'm
tell people this is for the next
generation you know they shouldn't have
to deal with this they should be picking
up seashells not picking up plastic
pellets up the beach as part of the
settlement Formosa agreed to zero spill
or loss moving forward of plastic
pellets both Wilson and tunnel believe
that should be the standard for all
companies moving forward boys he said it
tunnel said it's 100% preventable you
just have have the right protocols in
place at these plants to make sure when
pellets are being transferred or
manufactured that they're not lost and
they don't spill into the ocean you have
to clean up what is already there
because the damage has been done by the
event it cost money it cost money to put
those protocols in place it also cost
money to clean them up